[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Hello, everybody.
Wow.
I'm loud.
Welcome to Building
Massive Online Worlds
with SpatialOS and
Google Cloud Platform.
My name is Mark Mandel.
I'm Developer Advocate
for Google Cloud.
ROB WHITEHEAD: And
I'm Rob Whitehead.
I'm CTO at Improbable.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So before we get started,
let's get a sense of the room.
Hands up the people here
who are game developers.
Oh, more than I expected.
Hobbyist game developers?
All right, cool, people
who are into simulations?
Some.
Yeah.
Venn diagram.
Cool.
People who are just interested
because this seemed cool?
That's fine, too.
ROB WHITEHEAD: Awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
All right, fantastic.
I'll tell you what.
Since we're here, Rob, thank
you so much for joining us.
I really appreciate
you taking the time
to talk to us about SpatialOS.
So that everyone
has a sense of what
it is we're talking about
today why don't you give us
like the general overview
of what Improbable is
and what SpatialOS is all about.
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah, for sure.
We're Improbable.
We're a group about
150 of us disputed
across London, San Francisco.
And our goal is really
kind of building a platform
to let you go beyond
the traditional limits
of a single server and to build
massive, living, simulated
online worlds.
Either using them applied
to kind of video games,
as you can see in
this video, or using
them to understand
the real world,
like simulating a
city or an ecology.
So what's going on here?
This is an example
of a game built
with one of our partners
called "Worlds Adrift."
And this is a massively
living online world,
which is running in
the cloud, and it's
powered by not just a
single dedicated server,
like traditional games you're
used to, but actually hundreds
of game engines cooperating
and overlapping together
to simulate a world much bigger
than any single one could ever
deal with.
And connecting into it are
thousands of different players
all across the world.
Again, makes it more than a
single dedicated server or VM
could ever deal with.
MARK MANDEL: Jumping out
of YouTube is always fun.
Awesome.
So you may be
wondering why we're
talking about Improbable and
SpatialOS at Google Cloud Next.
So the answer to that really is
is that Google Cloud Platform
is always looking for
new partners that share
a desire for innovation
and especially
innovation in the game space.
We really want to
partner with people
who want to let people build--
oh, god, I'm going
to say it-- really
what's next in the
gaming world and really
just across the board as well.
To that end, we're
actually really
happy to be partnering
with Improbable
to help them develop the
SpatialOS games innovation
program.
Rob, can you tell us
about how that goes?
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah, for sure.
So when we kind of went out
into the games community,
we found there were
these fantastic
ideas people had about
leveraging this amount of cloud
resource to build like the next
generation of simulated living
game worlds.
And we found people
a bit apprehensive
in terms of the
cloud cost that they
might incur in terms of
their development and R&D.
And Google and
Improbable got together,
and the innovation
program allows
us to offer like free
development costs in terms
of cloud for people from
starting development
all the way through
to commercial launch.
So the idea is to
sort of allow people
to really kind of let loose
and experiment and try and do
some crazy things without being
worried about kind of the cost
they're going to
incur through that.
MARK MANDEL: So that
sounds pretty cool.
Why don't we check out
how that actually works?
ROB WHITEHEAD: Awesome.
So I'm going to kind
of talk on a high level
about our platform as a
service, and its kind of core
architecture, and how
you think about it,
and what the abstraction is
on top of traditional servers.
Then I'm going to give
you an actual live demo
on my laptop of it running
on my local machine.
And then we're going to
dive into some code snippets
and kind of show
you under the hood.
For those of you who
have coded with Unity3D,
you might find some of
the APIs quite familiar.
Who's actually used
Unity out of curiosity?
Great.
So for those of you
who are kind of maybe
aware, traditionally when
you have online game worlds,
they'll have a dedicated server.
And that's a process
running inside
either a dedicated server
somewhere on a bare metal
hardware or on a
VM in the cloud.
And all the clients
within that world
connect into that single server.
And this works
pretty well when you
have a small amount
of concurrent players,
or if you have a small
amount of simulation going on
if your world's
not that complex.
But you encounter
issues when you
want to have thousands or
tens of thousands of people
in the same environment,
and you want
to have worlds that
are truly living.
If you want to have
a game world which
has millions of trees
which actually grow,
in like a real ecology
and a real economy,
you kind of start to hit
the fundamental limits
of a single machine no matter
how many calls you get.
So the whole idea of SpatialOS
is it's a distributed operating
system.
So that is to say,
it's an abstraction
on top of lots of
computers, lots of VMs.
So you should treat it as one
big machine in some senses.
And the core idea is
rather than having
a single dedicated server,
which you'd normally
have, you know, Unity compiled
out as a Linux dedicated
server, or Unreal's
dedicated server,
SpatialOS actually orchestrates
a swarm of dedicated servers,
potentially hundreds
of thousands of them
all with overlapping
areas of interest.
All kind of combined together to
simulate a massive game world.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So basically kind of
what you're telling me
is it's kind of like
a traditional platform
as a service but just for
massive online persistent
worlds.
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah, exactly.
And you think about--
and the whole reason
we call it SpatialOS
is you think
about this big
cluster of machines
as a three dimensional
space, which
contains your computation.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So as a developer then, what
does the lifecycle look like?
How am I building my stuff?
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah, for sure.
So it's, again, a
traditional kind
of platform as a service style.
You have a set of CLI
tools and web tools you
download from spatialos.com.
You can do this today.
You could do it right now.
You should listen to
us instead, though.
Once you've downloaded
those tools,
we have integrations
into Unity, into Unreal,
and we also have base
language integration.
So you can write code which
works in this manner in C#,
C++, Java.
And then you just
use some CLI commands
to package up your
application, push it
into the SpatialOS platform.
And then sort of
on our side we're
going to be using
as much computation
as is necessary to
simulate your world.
So these are the
kind of cool words
which you use when you're
thinking about building
something with SpatialOS.
And some of you might
find some of these words
familiar, because they're very
much inspired by game engine
architecture.
And some of you might find
that-- like workers is
a new word we've
kind of invented,
but it's actually a
broadening and an abstraction
from things you're probably
already familiar with.
So in SpatialOS, the
core idea of the world
is it contains entities.
It contains things.
So in a video game, like you
saw "Worlds Adrift" before,
each player is an entity.
The rocks on the
floor are an entity,
the trees, which can be
chopped down, are entities,
and even the ships
are actually composed
of hundreds of entities.
So they really represent the
domain of your application.
You can imagine if you are using
SpatialOS to simulate a city,
you might use
entities to represent
road segments, buildings,
traffic signals,
all kinds of different things.
Then you have components.
So this is like a
traditional structure
of game engine architectures.
And what it lets you do
is rather than having
like sort of a really big,
monolithic ideas of objects,
it lets you compose
them out of pieces
which make it a lot
easier to reason about.
So rather than thinking
about a monster,
you think about something which
is a rigid body, which means
it can move in physical space.
It has a collider, which means
it can bump into other things.
And it has a
navigation component,
which defines the
idea of it having
a destination to go to and
some waypoints along the way.
So the interesting
thing here is workers.
Workers are-- I guess you can
think of them as microservices,
little pieces of code which
either are connecting in
over the internet, like
a game engine client,
or running within
SpatialOS itself,
which are authoritative
of parts of entities,
as in their components.
So you can imagine
taking a physics engine,
like PhysX, and having that
simulates all the rigid body
components of the
entities in the world.
But the magic which
is going on here
is maybe PhysX can only
simulate 10,000 rigid bodies,
and your gameworld has
one million rigid bodies.
What SpatialOS can do
is actually spin up
100 instances of that process,
distributed across a cluster,
and have them all
cooperate together.
And SpatialOS is handling
all the synchronization
and all the orchestration
that's going on for you.
So to kind of like
sort of bring it back
into a concrete example
based upon the video
you saw with "Worlds Adrift."
From their side, within
one of their worlds,
the worlds are about
50 by 50 kilometers,
and you're looking at kind
of over half a million
fully physically simulated
objects inside that game.
So creatures, players,
panels of a ship
can fall off and
fall onto the ground
and be completely persisted.
Each one of these
islands you saw
are kind of build out of
voxels through a user generated
content tool.
And those islands themselves
have about 3,000 entities,
from even like an egg
on the ground or a tree,
they're all entities.
And every single one of these
entries is fully persistent.
So the whole idea is
SpatialOS maintains
the data representation
of the world
completely distinct from
any one of these processes
or clients connected in.
So if you drop like
a sword in a bush,
and you kind of come
away, you should
be able to come back to
it, and years later it
should still be there.
And this is because--
you can think about SpatialOS
as an in memory database
which is maintaining
all those entities.
And in terms of examples of
components inside of "Worlds
Adrift," some of them are
kind of very familiar,
you might find, if
you're a game dev.
But within "Worlds Adrift,"
they're actually real--
like a real ecology
of creatures,
and they even have
components about pregnancy
and how hungry they are.
And it's very crazy how
much depth you can go into
to define those entities.
And then in terms
of workers, you
have your workers
running in the cloud.
So for "Worlds Adrift," they
have 200 Unity Linux instances
all cooperating together
to simulate the space.
And they have about
1,000 Unity clients,
which are players connecting
in all across the world
to simulate the world.
So again, something massive and
far bigger than any single game
engine could deal with.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
That sounds really great.
So why don't we cut to the
demo, and you can actually
show us this thing in action?
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah, for sure.
So this is where
it gets really fun.
So it's worth saying,
you know, SpatialOS
is a platform as a service.
It's a tool which lets
you run large scale
simulations in the cloud.
But often for local
development, it's
convenient to have
a local SpatialOS.
And SpatialOS can
use a single machine,
or it can use 1,000 machines.
So we can see here as it
using just a single machine
on my local machine.
And we're going to be using
a tutorial which is available
online right now for
our Unity integration.
So let's go ahead and start it.
So yeah, the idea
of this sort of demo
is it's like a little
diorama of SpatialOS.
It's going to show you
the core concepts at work.
And although we
can scale to maybe
hundreds of thousands times
larger than you'll see here,
it'll really kind of leave
you with the feeling of what's
going on under the hood.
It's working.
MARK MANDEL: Good.
ROB WHITEHEAD: So what I'm going
to run here on my local machine
is a traditional,
built out Unity client.
And I'm going to
be running around
as an awesome
little wizard, which
is going to be able to
go around and set things
on fire, which is going
to be really, really cute.
There we go.
So, you know, this is
pretty much like sort
of any kind of game you
might be familiar with.
And this little guy,
I can go around,
I can see things going on.
I can set things on fire.
And I can also set
the little people
on fire, which is not very
nice to do, but I can.
And it's definitely
going to happen.
I'm sorry.
I missed.
But you'll see it's like
just like any other game,
but already kind of
what you should see here
is the game world is actually
much bigger than what's
inside this single Unity client.
The worlds actually contain
tens of thousands of trees,
and there's actually another
base very similar to this
on the other side of the world.
But what's happening
is as I move around,
you kind of won't notice
it, but the subset
of the world I'm
interested in is
being streamed in by SpatialOS.
And as clients, the simulation
of those little dudes running
around isn't actually
being done on my client,
it's being done on a built
out, dedicated Unity server
running on my machine which
is connected into SpatialOS.
And this client, rather
than being connected
into the dedicated server,
is connected into SpatialOS,
and SpatialOS is managing
the interests of the world
as I go around.
OK.
I'm going to have to get
really accurate with this now.
Come on.
No, I missed.
It's all right.
We can come back a little
later when there's more people.
So the first thing
which I want to show you
is that's kind of what the
game client sees the world as.
But I want to show you what
SpatialOS sees the game
world as.
So this is the entire space.
Again, it's a relatively
small simulation.
It's about 10,000 entities.
And already you can see that
we're actually running not just
a single dedicated server,
but there are actually
two dedicated servers running
and overlapping together
to simulate a world kind of much
bigger than a single one could
deal with for an
extended period of time.
And if you zoom in
here, you can actually
see this overlapped area.
And what this is
showing you as well
is the canonical
data representation
of the entities
inside the world.
So although Unity
sees them when you
log in as a client as
these really high fidelity,
graphical assets, you can see
here I can go ahead and click
and this is a tree.
And if I go ahead and
like sort of click on it,
it can actually show me the
components of that entity.
And this is really important
having this agnostic
representation of the world,
because we don't care whether
the game engines and dedicated
servers have been written
in C#, or C++, or Java, or
whether you've used Unity
or Unreal.
This is this kind of canonical,
agnostic representation
of everything going on.
So we can already start to
do some fun things which
are really scary to do
on stage but actually
work out pretty well.
So one thing which
happens when you're
running not two but 200
or 2,000 game engines
is in the cloud
sometimes they'll crash.
Code has a mean time to failure.
So if I go ahead and
pull the power cord out
of one of these
workers, what's going
to happen is if you
actually zoom in,
you'll find the top right hand
side of the world is actually
still being simulated, but the
bottom left is actually paused.
It's almost like a
glitch in the matrix.
But if I zoom out, you'll
find that SpatialOS detected
the failure, and it's actually
started up a new worker
to replace it in this
top left hand corner.
And what we're showing off
here is our dynamic load
balancing algorithms whereby
two workers can actually
change their spatial area
of interest in real time
to deal with
fluctuations of load.
So if you have a really big
epicenter of combat going on,
you can actually have a
worker move to that area space
and shrink in and kind of
focus on what's happening.
Cool.
Let's go back and see if there's
more NPCs to have fun with.
Yeah, there's a lot more.
Oh, no.
That's a really bad idea.
It's all right.
One of my friends put me out.
Clearly nicer than me.
The other thing to show you here
as well is if I zoom in here,
this is actually
showing the subset
of the world which the client
is actually connected into.
And the little blue dots, if
you can see it, is my player.
And as I move around
the world, SpatialOS
is understanding the subset of
the world I'm interested in.
And it's going to go ahead and
move like a window of interest
within my world and streaming.
So this is again
demonstrating you
can have game
worlds substantially
larger than any single
instance of Unity
could ever deal with or
fit inside of memory.
And as you move
around, it's actually
streaming in just a subset of
the world you're interested in,
and it's going be keeping
you up to date there.
Cool.
So that pretty much
concludes the demo
if we want to dive into
some code examples.
MARK MANDEL: If we can
switch back, please.
Thank you.
All right, that
sounds really great.
So yeah, let's have a look
at some code examples,
and you can talk us through
how the actual coding
aspect of SpatialOS works.
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah, for sure.
So the first thing
to talk about here
is the SpatialOS
schema language.
So I talked before
about SpatialOS
having a kind of canonical data
representation of the world,
which is completely distinct
of any language or any kind
of client or any kind of
server, like Microservice,
or kind of game
engine connected in.
And this is how you define that.
So this lets you define the
abstract idea of an entity
without any understanding of its
implementation, which gives you
the flexibility to use
whatever tools you want.
So this example here--
I'm going to show you the
implementation of flammability
within Unity.
And it starts off by defining
this canonical abstract idea
of a component.
So I'm going to call
it flammability,
and I'm going to give it
the idea of a property being
is on fire, because obviously
I want to have some state for,
is this thing not
on fire or on fire?
And the thing I'm going to
add as well is a command.
So commands are
SpatialOS's RPC mechanism
which lets two workers
communicate with each other.
And I'm going to define
a command here called
ignites, which is if I'm
something which is on fire,
and I'm something
which is not on fire,
I can send an ignites command to
the thing which is not on fire
and make it ignite.
And the awesome thing
Spatial is doing
for you is it's going
to automatically root
that RPC to whatever
worker is authoritative
on that component at
any point in time.
So you had this kind of really
nice transparency going on.
And if it turns out you're
the actual worker who's
authoritative for that command,
it's going to short circuit it,
and you're going to get sort of
that efficiency already built
in.
So this first part
of the example
is going to be about our
implementation of the Unity
server code.
So this is the
code running inside
of the workers you saw before--
the two overlapping processes.
And those of you who kind of--
who has written Unity code
before in C#?
Any chance?
Yeah.
So you'll see something here
which is quite familiar,
which is a Unity
monitor behavior.
And the thing which is cool
and the thing which is new
is that first line where
you see require flammability
right there.
So SpatialOS's SDK has a really
powerful co-generation tool
built in, which takes
those components you
defined in the SpatialOS
schema language
and generates idiomatic APIs
in whatever kind of platform
you're writing clients or
dedicated server processes for.
So in Unity, it's going
to go ahead and write
these classes which demonstrate
the ability to read and write
from a particular component.
In Unreal, we'll actually
generate you act to components,
and you'll be able to use the
blueprint visual scripting
tool to actually wire up
and do things that way.
Or if you are kind of writing
like a small C# microservice
or something in Java,
you're going to get, again,
some sort of relatively
straightforward APIs,
which you can use to hook
into the different parts
of an entity.
And the first thing I'm
going to do in this sample
here is add in an
implementation for ignites.
So this is saying when
someone tells me to ignite,
here is an implementation
of the call back to call.
So this is the next bit of code.
So those of you who kind of
aren't familiar with Unity,
it has an idea of a trigger.
So this is a collider which
you can actually walk through.
But when you walk
through and into it,
it's going to fire an event
to tell you that somebody's
kind of gone into it.
And this is a really
good tool inside of Unity
for dealing with
objects kind of moving
within proximity of
each other and you
getting alerted of that.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to use the trigger
system of Unity
and kind of tie
that into SpatialOS.
So that when somebody moves
into my trigger region,
I'm going to check--
am I on fire?
And if I'm on fire,
I'm going to send
the thing that moved into
my trigger region a command.
And that command is
either going to--
what SpatialOS is
going to do for you
is it's going to work out--
is that entity on
my worker locally?
Am I authoritative for it?
Then I'm going to invoke
the command locally.
If it's not, it's going to
send it through SpatialOS,
and it's going to
work out whatever
worker across the cluster is
authoritative for that entity,
and it's going to
invoke the RPC.
And it's worth noting
here I didn't write
any kind of serialization code.
I didn't write any data
synchronization code.
It's all handled for you.
You just kind of
invoke this method,
and we're going to choose the
most appropriate thing to do.
And the final thing to see
here is the ignite handler.
So this is when me, myself, I've
received an RPC from somebody
to make myself ignite.
And this is the implementation
I've defined in Unity code
on the dedicated
server, the handler.
And what you can see I'm going
to be doing here is checking,
am I not on fire?
If I'm not on fire, I'm going
to send a new update which
sets me on fire.
So when you do that dot
send, what's going to happen
is that dedicated
server worker is
going to send a message
into SpatialOS for you.
And SpatialOS is
going to work out
exactly what other workers need
to know about that property
update.
So maybe there are
1,000 clients all
watching this tree, like,
really excited for it
to spontaneously set on fire.
And when that-- pyromaniacs
everywhere-- when it ignites,
SpatialOS is going
to do that kind
of distributed
synchronization across all
these different workers.
And those workers might be
running on different machines
across the world.
They might be running
on different machines
in the cloud.
We handle that kind of big
synchronization effort.
And you didn't write any
network synchronization code.
You didn't write any
kind of sort of--
any kind of reliable
UDP stuff going on.
We're using like sort
of best in class,
like sort of transpose stuff to
go ahead and do that for you.
And then this is kind
of the fun bit, I guess,
which is although, SpatialOS,
one of the core ideas of it
is that it maintains for every
component of every entity there
is only ever one worker which
is authoritative for it, which
really helps in terms
of race conditions
and that kind of thing.
There may be
arbitrarily many workers
interested in
reading a component.
So you could imagine there
being thousands of clients,
again, like, interested
in that tree.
And what you use in this
case is rather than injecting
in a flammability
reader writer interface,
you inject in a reader.
And this reader is
going to give you
callbacks for being
told when the component
data of that entity is updated.
So what I've done
here is when I enable
I'm adding on a
visualization update.
So I'm going to make
a callback for when
this object either becomes on
fire or ceases to be on fire.
And then in classic
Unity fashion,
I've got a Particle system,
which I've kind of like sort of
got wired up here.
You can imagine it being
inside of a game object
inside of Unity.
And based upon the
abstract idea of SpatialOS,
it's flamability
being on fire and not
on fire, I'm going to go
ahead and actually utilize
that with a Particle system
being enabled and disabled.
And this is a very
nice decoupling.
You might be familiar
with it if you're
kind of from the webdev
world of your model
being decoupled from your view.
And this is really nice, because
this flames visualizer is
the one which is used on trees.
You can imagine the one which
is being used for NPCs with them
kind of flailing around
their hands in a really cute
and terrifying fashion is
a different piece of code.
So it lets you kind of really
nicely compartmentalize
the implementation
of the components
from the visualizations
which might take place
on different kinds of clients.
And you can even
imagine the visualizer
code on a mobile device,
which is connected
into the same world, might
use like a sprite rather
than a full on Particle system.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So you showed us a
bunch of Unity code.
Just so we're all
aware as well--
this works on Unity.
This works on Unreal,
even on custom engines.
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah, exactly.
So as I said before,
the APIs we generate,
we have really, really
deep integrations
into Unreal and
Unity, which lets
you have these really
nice idiomatic interfaces.
But if you want to write to some
microservice to do something,
like say, a star pathfinding
for your NPCs moving around,
you can use our low layered
language worker integration
instead.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
All right, so we are here
at Cloud Next, obviously.
So not only is it great to
hear from you about SpatialOS
and how it works,
but I'm guessing
there's some people in the
audience who may want to hear
about why you're with us.
Why are you with
Google Platform?
Excellent.
So I know you use a few
different products of ours
on Google Platform, the first
of which is Compute Engine.
So I know from my perspective,
developer advocacy,
quite often I speak a lot
about the cool new shiny stuff
or the stuff that
automatically scales,
like F Engine or
something like Kubernetes.
But you use a lot of virtual
machines on Compute Engine.
So if you're not familiar,
like Compute Engine,
those are the
virtual machines that
run on Google Cloud Platform.
You spin them up,
spin them down.
They're very traditional
in what they use.
Can you talk about your
experience using those?
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah, for sure.
So for clarity,
SpatialOS itself is
a platform as a
service, which means
you have an account
with the SpatialOS
and you use those CLI tools
to deploy it to the cloud.
But under the hood,
we're actually
using Google Cloud's
actual infrastructure
to be able to run and
scale your simulation.
And when we were choosing
cloud providers to run on,
we found that Google
Cloud Platform
had some favorable
characteristics
for certain kinds
of things we use.
So when I talked about "Worlds
Adrift" running before,
it's actually running about
500 cores worth of compute
across about 50 machines.
And they're actually good--
VMs running on Google
Compute Engine.
And when you type in spatial
deploy, which is the command
to actually go and start
your simulation, what we're
doing under the hood is
actually starting Google GCE VMs
to actually be running
the power and the kind
of the workhorse of all the
simulation going on here.
So the thing we actually found
with Compute Engine, which
made it really good for
our use cases, is we
want small teams to be able
to iterate really fast.
And we want you to come up
with a really crazy idea
for a multiplayer
game, write some code,
and then just run
it in the cloud,
and then share a link
with your friends,
and then you can all
log in and play it.
And the provisioning
time of VM, which
is the time you say, hey, I
want a VM to here is your VM,
is a really important part
of that iteration process,
especially when you're
working with teams.
So the awesome thing
about GCE for us
is the provisioning
times, which we
found to be quite favorable
compared to other cloud
providers.
And what that means for you
as a SpatialOS developer is
you've got that faster
turn around time,
and you can experiment quicker.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
And I think you were also
looking at custom VMs.
So if you're not actually
familiar with those either,
Google Cloud Platform
gives you the ability
to create VMs with exactly
the same number of CPUs--
exactly the number of CPUs
and memory that it is you
want to use.
And that works very
well for you as well.
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah.
It's just something we're kind
of investigating right now.
When you imagine running a game
engine like Unity in the cloud,
you want to make
sure that you don't
have any memory you're
not really using
or any CPU you're not using.
And from that side, if we can
better pack Unity instances
on to VMs, it's
cheaper for us to run,
which means we can make
it cheaper for you to use.
And that's a very
powerful tool there,
especially because game engines
are quite weird beasts when
they run in the
cloud, and they have
quite strange kind of resourcing
requirements sometimes.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So when you and I got together
and started talking about this,
we also started talking about
the Google Cloud Platfrom
Network.
Which I don't know if we
necessarily talk about as much,
but I think it's really
cool and interesting.
Obviously or possibly
not obviously,
we run on the same
infrastructure
as, say, Maps, and Gmail, and
all the other Google services.
And as you may have heard
from all the stuff that's
been going on around
Spanner, the network
that runs Google
Cloud Platform enables
us to do some really cool stuff
and is exceptionally fast.
I think you've had a pretty
similar experience running
your stuff on the Google
Platforms Network.
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah, indeed.
So the first thing about
real time multiplayer games
which is quite different than
traditional applications is
rather than kind of using TCP
as the underlying transport,
a lot of them are
based around UDP.
And that's because when you're
receiving a firehose of, say,
60 updates a second
of a player position,
if you drop some
of those packets,
TCP is going to go ahead
and go, hold on, hold on.
And, you know, you're
going to get these delays
whilst it tries to reassemble
and give you a reliable stream.
But with a player position, I'd
rather get the next position
if I miss one.
And UDP's a natural kind of
choice of transport for that.
And it's basically best
in class for the industry.
And what ends up happening
is people end up--
there's really popular
open source libraries,
like RakNet, which are
abstractions on top of UDP
to give you semi-reliability.
So you can imagine their
position update of one
of those panels falling down
in "Worlds Adrift" is actually
being sent unreliably with UDP.
Something like one of
those RPCs to ignite
is actually sent reliably.
So RakNet lets
you kind of have--
you can turn the dial from sort
of fully unreliable to fully
reliable.
And in terms of how that applies
to Google and it's networking--
cloud providers, I
guess, traditionally
were really built around
scaling web services.
So I've got some SAST Facebook
for dogs or something,
and I want to kind of scale
out the different 10 web
servers which are hosting that.
And when we went ahead
and tried to start
using cloud providers for
UDP, especially like firehoses
of UDP packets,
you'd find there are
limitations in terms of the--
especially with
small UDP packets--
how many of them you can send
per second on a single VM.
And when we were kind
of profiling around,
we found Google's networking
had a really solid kind
of performance in terms
of being able to, I think,
send like hundreds of
thousands of packets
a second from a single VM.
And that really
translates into being
able to have richer, bigger,
more interesting worlds
and have more players packed
onto a single server, which
is an important part of
having really dense combat
and really interesting gameplay.
And yeah, it's
worth saying as well
that we use like sort of
clusters all over the world.
So we have clusters in the US.
We have clusters in Europe.
We have clusters in Asia.
And they're running on
Google Compute Machines,
but people are connecting
over the internet
using Google's
networking infrastructure
to connect into those
SpatialOS deployments.
MARK MANDEL: Now,
something we don't probably
talk about that often
necessarily in the game space
is storage, right?
So you also do really neat
stuff with Google Cloud Storage.
So again, if you're not familiar
with Google Cloud Storage,
this is the place for
you to store binary files
on our system.
The nice thing about
it is that we have
nice things like edge caching.
You can store a
petabytes of data on it.
It'll do regional and
multiregional replication
for you out of the box.
So it comes with a
lot of good stuff,
but I've seen you use it in
kind of interactive ways.
It kind of works really nicely.
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah,
it's really cool.
So you saw before what
SpatialOS sees a game world as.
It sees it as just dots in
a kind of arbitrary three
dimensional space.
But when you're kind
of walking in your game
and you encounter an
object, maybe it's
an object you actually
haven't seen before.
SpatialOS doesn't
actually contain
in its in-memory representation
the actual mesh data and sort
of the assets which
represent the object.
All it contains is a pointer
into Google Cloud Storage
which contains the actual Unity
asset bundle you download.
And this makes a ton of
sense because SpatialOS
is optimized for high
amounts of data throughput.
It's optimized for
components updating maybe
hundreds of times a second.
We don't want to be
storing kind of blobs
of megabytes or gigabytes of
data in that thing as well.
It doesn't make sense.
So we kind of have this tandem
thing which makes sense.
So when you kind of fly around
in a ship in "Worlds Adrift,"
and you see an island
you haven't seen before.
What's going to
happen is SpatialOS
will say, oh, that island
is called island 4709.
And then using SpatialOS's APIs,
you can actually hook into our,
we call it our
Assembly Service, which
is going to fetch to you
from Google Cloud Storage
the appropriate island for you
to download as an asset bundle,
stream it in real time
using your game engine,
and spawn into the game.
And when we were
kind of choosing GCS,
traditionally you
kind of think that you
need to use a CDN for
this kind of thing.
But we actually
profiled that GCS
against sort of
conventional CDN providers,
and we found it was comparable.
And we were using
this anyway for how
we store a lot of
things within Spatial,
so it made total sense for us.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
So you're using a
bunch of products
from Google Cloud
Platform, which is great,
but you're also using some of
our open source stuff as well.
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: You're
actually using
one of my favorite open
source projects, GRPC.
So GRPC is a high performance,
open-source universal remote
procedure call framework.
It actually-- yeah,
it came out of Stubby.
So it came out of, historically,
our internal remote procedure
call framework called Stubby.
It's really, really cool.
It's works really, really fast.
It does streaming data
really, really well.
It has been a huge thing around
how we talk about microservices
at Google and Google Cloud.
Can you talk about how
you've been using it?
I think it's really
interesting for games.
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah, for sure.
So you can imagine with games
bandwidth is absolutely key
and performance
is absolutely key.
You don't want to be firehosing
around like JSON blobs which
represent entity position when
you're sending hundreds of them
a second per entity,
and you might have
1,000 entities in your scene.
And also when you're
running, like Improbable,
we have a team of
around 100 engineers.
We have a constellation
of different microservices
that make up SpatialOS.
So besides the
actual runtime, which
is this kind of in-memory,
spatial simulation
representation, we
have microservices
for things like
accounts, billing,
storing deployment
snapshots of your world,
storing the binary assets you
download, like your trees,
et cetera.
And we reached a
point where we were
using kind of a restful
interface for all those things.
But you start to
have a lot of issues
arise, because you don't
have a typed representation
of that interface,
and you sort of
have teams like stepping
on each other's toes.
And you have to rely on
large amounts of unit testing
and integration
testing to actually
make sure your software works.
But under the hood
for us, we used
GRPC for all of our
microservice architecture.
And actually with Spacial, if
you type in spatial deploy,
that's actually using GRPC
calls to talk to our platform
to kick off that deployment.
And another thing we actually
have in the pipeline as well
is that inspector you saw,
that kind of WebGL accelerated
entity view, when you
kind of move it around it
actually sets up
a streaming query
for a subset of the worlds to be
streamed down into the browser.
And again, GRPC looks like
a very powerful candidate
to kind of help
accelerate that as well.
And it's kind of based
on HTTP, too, as well.
So it's really nice for kind
of lots and lots of requests
and responses really quickly and
also for streaming responses.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
Sweet.
So you're showing us some
really amazing stuff.
Super excited about
SpatialOS, I think
it's really exciting tech.
Can you tell us about what
plans you have for the future?
What can we see?
What's coming up
down the pipeline?
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah.
So there's kind of two
different angles to talk about.
So the natural first thing is
about scale and performance.
We really want to be
this platform where
you can have game worlds, or
even simulations of the living
world, which are a
kind of reality scale.
And by that we mean
millions of concurrent plays
in the same environment
with high fidelity physics,
maybe even in VR, and
billions of simulated entities
which have rich AI,
they're fully physical,
and they're fully persistent.
And all of our dev
teams at Spacial,
especially on our
R&D side, are focused
on trying to push the
capabilities of SpatialOS
further and further.
And that really comes
down to how many clients
you can have in
that world, and also
how many servers can participate
in this single, uncharted,
seamless spatial computation.
And I'm really excited
to see the direction we
go in the next couple of years.
We kind of want to
build the Matrix.
That's probably something we--
it's a story for
another time, but that's
kind of-- you can imagine
the foundations of it
based upon that.
And then the other side is--
now we're kind of--
friends of Google is looking
at the constellation of tools
and services they have and
how people could easily
tie them in working
with SpatialOS to do
some awesome new things.
So you can imagine
a game world which
is like a successor to a Pokemon
Go geo game, where you're
using Google Maps data and
streaming that in and using
Google Maps objects to
represent SpatialOS entities.
That could be really exciting.
Or on our kind of non-gaming
side, doing city simulations
that are actually based upon
Google Maps's sort of traffic
information and
building information.
That will be really exciting.
We have some sort of
interesting angles
we're looking at
with kind of YouTube
and how streaming plays a
part in real, living worlds.
And I think there's
some exciting stuff
we can talk about soon on that.
And then, again, another kind
of Skynet-esque kind of thing
to think about is integrating
in technologies like TensorFlow
into Spatial.
So I talked before
about the workers
that connect into SpatialOS
can be completely arbitrary.
So I had a hackathon
team a few weeks ago,
and they actually integrated a
C++ TensorFlow worker running
in interactive mode into
SpatialOS and was doing
reinforcement learning of these
little entities kind of moving
around and eating things
inside of Spatial.
And they were kind of
sharing the same brain.
So as you had multiple
entities in the same world,
they were actually
combining together
their learning information.
And I think the
idea of SpatialOS
is almost like a kindergarten
or a sandbox for AIs
to learn about physical systems
and learn how to interact
is a really exciting
proposal as well.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic.
All right.
Well, we're going to
have plenty of time
for questions, which is great.
First of all, Rob, thank you so
much for joining us on stage.
But before we go, do you
have any final thoughts,
or like, the one
thing the people need
to remember about SpatialOS
before they end up
leaving the room?
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah.
It's not crazy magic technology.
You can literally go to
spatialos.com right now.
You can download the SDK.
You can play around with it.
In terms of what you can use it
for, you can use it with Unity,
and you can sort of be
running things in the cloud.
You can be using Unreal.
And yeah, you can also be
using like whatever language
or whatever tools
you're familiar with.
They're very easy to integrate
into SpatialOS's representation
of the world.
And in terms of
the two things we
want to let people do with
Spatial on the gaming side--
one is teams, no
matter how big or small
they are, being able
to do fundamentally
new kinds of things
in the game industry.
So game worlds which
are truly persistent
have millions of
living objects inside
of them, tens of
thousands of people
inside of them simultaneously.
We want to make that possible.
And also because SpatialOS
is a platform as a service,
we want to take small
teams, teams like Bossa,
who don't really have
an infrastructure team.
They don't have
network programmers.
They don't have all the
people you traditionally
expect you need to
build persistent worlds.
They're going ahead.
They're picking up SpatialOS
and its Unity integration,
and they're doing things
which really they'd
find like fundamentally
impossible,
or they'd need to hire
beyond their means
to make it possible.
So it's about everybody being
able to do fundamentally
new kinds of things,
and small teams
being able to go further without
any specialist techniques
and tools.
MARK MANDEL: Building
the next games.
ROB WHITEHEAD: Building-- yeah.
MARK MANDEL: I just, I can't.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
OK, it's terrible.
I know.
Excellent.
So if people want to learn more
about SpatialOS, spatialos.com,
like you mentioned.
The GitHub has-- the GitHub--
GitHub has the
Hello World sample.
They're available for you to do.
If people want to reach out
to you on Twitter or email?
ROB WHITEHEAD: Yeah,
yeah, go ahead.
The forums of SpatialOS are
really active and definitely
worth checking out.
And the demo I ran
through today is actually
the exact demo you use when
you sign up for SpatialOS.
You get access, and you kind
of go through your first kind
of Hello World tutorial.
You'll be running
through exactly what we
ran through here,
but the next step
is deploying it onto the
cloud and then sharing it
with people.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, so if anyone
has any questions,
there is a microphone
standing right there.
So if you could come
up to it, and if you
could ask your questions so I
can get it on the recording,
that would be great.
But otherwise, thank
you very much to Rob.
ROB WHITEHEAD: Thank you
very much for having me.
MARK MANDEL: Do we
have any questions?
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]